let's explore the notion of a polynomial
so this seems like a very complicated
word but if you break it down they'll
start to make sense especially when we
start to see examples of polynomials so
the first part of this word let me
underline it with poly this comes from
Greek for many and you see poly a lot in
the English language referring to the
notion of many of something so in this
case it's many no meals and no meal
comes from Latin from the Latin Roman
for name so you could view this as many
names but in the mathematical context
it's really referring to many terms and
we're going to talk and a little bit
about what a term really is but I get a
tangible sense of what are polynomials
and what are not polynomials let me give
you some examples and then we could
write some may be more formal rules for
them so an example of a polynomial could
be 10 X to the seventh power minus 9 x
squared plus 15 X to the third plus 9
this is a polynomial another example of
a polynomial 9a squared minus 5 even if
I just have one number even if I were to
just write the number six that can
officially be considered a polynomial if
I were to write 7x squared minus three
let me do is another variable 7y squared
minus 3y plus pi that 2 would be a
polynomial so these are examples of
polynomials what are examples of things
that are not polynomials well if I were
to replace the seventh power right over
here with the negative seventh power so
if I were to write 10x to the negative
seven power minus nine x squared plus 15
X to the third power plus nine this
would not be a polynomial so I think you
might be sensing a rule here for what
makes something upon no meal you have to
have non-negative powers of your
variable in each of the terms and I just
use that word term so let me
explain it because it will help me
explain what a polynomial is a
polynomial is something that is it that
is made up of a sum of terms and so for
example in this first polynomial the
first term is 10 X to the seventh the
second term is negative 9x squared the
next term is 15 X to the third and then
the last term maybe you could say the
fourth term is nine and you can see
something let me underline these so
these are all these are all terms this
is a four term polynomial right over
here and you could say hey wait this
thing you wrote in red this also has
four terms but we have to put a few more
rules for to officially be a polynomial
especially a polynomial in one variable
each of those terms are going to be made
up of a coefficient this is the thing
that multiplies the variable to some
power so in the first term the
coefficient is 10 and let me write this
word down coefficient so another fancy
word but it's just a thing that's
multiplied in this case times the
variable which is X to the seventh power
so the Co the first coefficient is 10
the next coefficient and actually let me
be careful here because the second
coefficient here is negative 9 so we are
looking at coefficients the third
coefficient here is 15 and you can view
this fourth term or this fourth number
as the coefficient because this could be
re-written as instead of just writing as
9 you could write it as 9x to the 0
power and then it looks a little bit
clearer like a coefficient so in general
a polynomial is the sum of a finite
number of terms where each term has a
coefficient which I could represent with
the letter a being multiplied by a
variable being raised to a non-negative
integer power so this right over here is
the coefficient it can be if we're
dealing well I don't want to get too
technical could we give a positive
negative number it could be any real
number we have our variable and then the
exponent here has to be non-negative
non-negative integer so here the reason
why what I wrote in red is not a
polynomial is because here I have an
exponent that is a negative integer
let's give some other examples of things
that are not polynomials so if I were to
change the second one to sort of 9a
squared if I wrote it as 9a to the one
half power minus five
this is not a polynomial because this
exponent right over here it is no longer
an integer it's one half and this is the
same thing as nine times the square root
of a minus five this also would not be a
polynomial or if I were to write nine a
to the a power minus five also not a
polynomial because here the exponent is
a variable it's not a non-negative
integer so all of these are examples of
polynomials so there's a few more pieces
of terminology that are valuable to know
polynomials is the general polynomial is
a general term for one of these
expressions that has multiple terms a
finite number so not an infinite number
and each of the terms has this form but
there's more specific terms for when you
have only one term or two terms or three
terms so when you have one term it's
called a monomial so this is a monomial
this is an example of a monomial which
we could write at 6 x2 0 but you could
also another example of a monomial might
be 10 10 Z to the 15th power that's also
a monomial your coefficient could be pi
pi whoops
it could be pi so we could write pi x
times B to the fifth power any of these
would be monomials so it's a binomial or
binomials where you have two terms
monomial mono for one one term binomial
is you have two terms so this right over
here is a binomial by
no meal you have two terms and all of
these are polynomials but these are sub
classifications so it's by no Milly of
one two terms another example of a
binomial would be would be 3y to the
third plus 5y once again you have two
terms that have this form right over
here now you'll also hear the term
trinomial
well trinomials when you have three
terms try no meal and this right over
here is an example this is the first
term this is the second term and this is
the third term now the next word that
you will hear often in the context with
polynomials is the notion of the degree
of a polynomial and you might hear
people say what is the degree of a
polynomial or what is the degree of a
given term of a polynomial so let's
start with the degree of a given term so
let's go to this polynomial over here we
have this first term 10 X to the seventh
the degree is the power that we're
raising the variable to so this is a 7th
degree term the second term is a second
degree term
the third term is a third degree term
and you could view this constant term
which is really just nine you could do
that as sometimes people say the
constant term sometimes people will say
the zeroth degree term now people are
talking about the degree of the entire
polynomial they're going to say well
what is the degree of the highest term
or the term with the highest degree that
degree will be the degree of the entire
polynomial so this first polynomial this
is a seventh degree polynomial this one
right over here is a second degree
polynomial because it has a second
degree term and that's the highest
degree term this right over here is a
third degree you could even say third
degree binomial because it's highest
degree term has degree 3 if they said 5
Y to the seventh instead of 5 Y well
then it would be a seventh degree
binomial this right over here is a 15
degree monomial this is a second-degree
trinomial now the last thing I
a few more things I will introduce you
to is the idea of a leading term and a
leading coefficient let me write this
down the notion of what it means to be
leading well it usually means it can
mean whatever is the first term or the
coefficient if you're saying leading
term it's the first term and if you're
saying leading coefficient is the
coefficient in the first term but it's
oftentimes associated with a polynomial
being written in standard form so
standard form standard form is where you
write the terms in degree order starting
with the highest degree term so for
example what I have up here this is not
in standard form because I do have the
highest degree term first but then I
should go to the next highs which is the
X to the third but here I wrote x
squared next so this is not standard if
I wanted to write it in standard form it
would be 10 X to the seventh power which
is the highest degree term it's a degree
7 then 15 X to the third so + 15 X to
the third which is the next highest
degree then negative 9x squared is the
next highest degree term and then the
lowest degree term here is plus 9 or
plus 9x to 0 now this is in standard
form I've written the terms in order of
decreasing degree with the highest
degree first and here it's clear that
your leading term is 10 X to the seventh
because it's the first one and our
leading coefficient here is the number
10 so there's a lot in that video but
hopefully that the notion of a
polynomial isn't seeming too intimating
at this point and these are really
useful words to be familiar with as you
continue on on your math journey